j'ai une bonne très bonne place pour
vous j'ai passé oui c'est moi d'abord
signé de bonnes classes et paris n'y a
pas de mauvaise place au mauvais maîtres
n'ont que des mauvais domestique
tu les figures pourrait vous arriver des
choses heureuses avec de la conduite
google avec de l'inconduite faut dire ça
dépend des façons de voir bercy joseph
vous avez une belle poilade merci madame
vous en changez tout de suite eu madame
alors encore un peu plus cette fois je
dis toi madame
d'abord matinaux priori interpol cette
femme de chambre conçu pour madame qu'il
ait remboursé mesures prises à l'avenir
je vous prie de ne pas rester si
longtemps de leur consulat qu'est ce que
vous dites je ne dis rien madame le jour
de la rentrée vous avez oublié
la viande de chien apporte de nombreux
ports témoin du film
bon apportez vos décisions et dépêché
vue on peut pas obliger une femme a fait
ce qu'elle devait faire
je voulais déjà dit je n'aime pas qu'on
se mettre du parfum elle madame c'est
loin des studios se faire trancher cette
réalité
ragde google s'engage pas dans ma vie
sans réfléchir
tel que je me suis trompé sur
quand je pense d'une cuisinière par
exemple tient chaque jour d'enseignement
les vies de ces lettres pour une pincée
d'arsenic la place du sel
bien là faut-il que nous ayons tout de
même un site unique